Un peu au nord,
on a un exemple de ce que cela pourrait être :
la Silicon Valley.
Le secteur entier du capital-risque s'est développé autour de l'idée
que si les gens ont de bonnes idées et l'envie de les mettre en œuvre,
on doit leur donner beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup d'argent.
(Rires)
Bien, mais quelle est notre stratégie pour Theresa et Baakir ?
Il n'y a pas d'incubateur pour eux,
pas d'accélérateur, pas de bourse.
Jobana, Sintia et Bertha, sont-elles si différentes que ça
des Mark Zuckerberg du monde ?
Baakir a de l’expérience et des références.
C'est sur lui que je parierais.
Considérez cela comme une invitation
à revoir cette stratégie imparfaite.
Saisissons cette opportunité
pour oublier ce récit passé et erroné,
écouter et observer de vraies histoires,
des histoires superbement complexes,
au sujet de ces gens marginalisés,
de leurs familles et leurs communautés.
Je vais prendre une minute pour parler à ma communauté.
On ne peut pas attendre
que quelqu'un autre le fasse correctement.
Souvenons-nous de ce dont on est capables,
de tout ce qu'on a bâti au prix de notre sang, notre sueur et nos rêves,
des rouages qui continuent de tourner,
et des gens qui ont tenu bon grâce à notre travail épuisant.
Souvenons-nous qu'on est magiques.
Si vous avez besoin d'inspiration pour rafraîchir votre mémoire,
lisez « La Parabole du semeur » d'Octavia Butler.
Écoutez la « Lettre de la prison de Birmingham » du révérend King.
Écoutez « First Writing Since » récité par Suheir Hammad,
ou Esperanza Spalding interpréter « Black Gold ».
Posez votre regard sur l'art de Kehinde Wiley
ou de Favianna Rodriguez.
Regardez les mains de votre grand-mère,
ou droit dans les yeux de quelqu'un qui vous aime.
On est magiques.
Individuellement, on n'a pas beaucoup de richesse et de pouvoir
mais collectivement, personne ne peut nous arrêter.
Et on dépense beaucoup de notre temps et de notre énergie
à nous organiser pour exiger un changement
de systèmes qui n'ont pas été faits pour nous.
Au lieu d'essayer de changer la structure des moyens actuels,
nous devons en créer de nouveaux.
Utilisons le pouvoir collectif dont on dispose
pour inventer et donner vie
à de nouvelles façons de vivre qui nous conviennent.
Desmond Tutu parle du concept d'Ubuntu
dans le contexte du processus de vérité et de réconciliation sud-africain
entrepris à la fin de l'Apartheid.
Selon lui, cela veut dire :
« Mon humanité est piégée, est inextricablement liée à la vôtre ;
nous faisons partie d'un paquet de vies. »
Un paquet de vies.
Le processus de vérité et de réconciliation
a commencé en soulevant les voix de ceux qui ne sont pas entendus.
S'il faut que ce pays respecte sa promesse de liberté et de justice pour tous,
il faut qu'on soulève les voix des nôtres qui ne sont pas entendus,
celles des gens comme Jobana, Sintia et Bertha,
Theresa et Baakir.
Il faut tirer profit de leurs solutions et de leurs idées.
Il faut écouter leurs vraies histoires,
leurs histoires, belles et compliquées.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)